Developing games for me
Similar to the need to breathe
Sunlight, air intake, drinking water and toys
I wanted to achieve something from a young age.
It is a strong desire, such as breathing and life needs.
Some believe that developing games alone makes me feel lonely
But this is not true at all
Because developing games on my own allows me
An opportunity to work with authors and vocal talent from around the world
In order to offer our product to players from all over the world.
This is what happened in the previous game I developed
Which has been installed 5 million times on Google Play
I got 16,000 comments.
I love electronic music
And some geometric shapes.
With the addition of mathematics and physics
Magnetized, for example
Enjoy the old fashioned style with a little dancing music.
Beat Stomper has modern EDM music.
The music of the game "Push & Pop" resembles the music of the 1980s
With the addition of 2.5D optical pattern.
The three games may look alike
But that's the fun part of gaming development
The use of limited resources
To explore unlimited opportunities.
When I was young, I was playing with my brother
All the classic games of the time.
My favorite game was a shooting game from a spaceship.
We were looking for this kind of great shooting games for a long time.
Finally, I decided with my brothers to develop a game by ourselves.
That's why we called the workshop the name "Uwan".
At first, we used Java to develop games.
At this time, there were no global platforms
So, I was marketing my toys locally only.
Then we launched our first mobile game
"Lightning Fighter 2"
Which was downloaded more than a million times after launch.
Thanks to Google Play Store Store Experiences
The "Lightning Fighter 2" installation rate has increased to 91% in Indonesia.
As well as Lightning Fighter 2
We also designed a strategic correction game "Lightning Rangers"
Which require more server-related technologies.
So, we decided to use Google Cloud, which helped us a lot in developing the game.
We used Labs in the Google Play Alpha Beta
For ratings comments in numbers from the players before launching the product
As well as to improve game quality.
The goal of developing games is to touch the hopes of every player
This is the ultimate goal.
OPUS came up with exploration and stories.
Every Saturday night, we hope the players can
From enjoying touching stories by exploring the games we offer.
This experience is like reading a wonderful novel.
Using a background service like "Google Play Services"
We can update games more quickly
To provide the best aspects of our games to all users.
For average revenue per user and successful referral rate,
OPUS Earth Project developed
By more than 200% in a very short period.
This is for an independent gaming developer like me
Consider a great help.